I have never once in my entire life
jumped off of a cage and did a backflip
except for that one time wow I finally
come to the UFC get a first round
knockout over a top five opponent become
the guy yeah and then decide to climb up
for the first time ever and do a back
flip off the top and then I promised
myself I would never ever do that again
Dan does not love that no no but it was
you know looking back yeah I was way up
there like 15 ft in the air that's
fantastic Gage she does it every time
yeah was it after the Tony Ferguson face
kick knockout that you did four
consecutive standing back flips I think
it was four four in a row right there
that's just That's Heavy and then like
what makes the difference if you're
going to do it off the cage or on the
flat what's crazy actually is